what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back from my season 7 finale breakdown
video there were a few things that I
want to put into question about this
episode but I must say I love the way it
ended with the wall coming down I have
been waiting for this day to come for a
very long time although I do not want to
see the show end I do want to see the
Great War take place I am praying that
torment and barrack were able to survive
that attack somehow I'm really not sure
how they would be able to escape with
the dead all around them but I am hoping
they didn't get crushed under all that
ice coming down I do not want those guys
to go out like that but it didn't look
good for them unfortunately with the way
things played out it looks like Cersei
is gonna live until the very end of this
series there is no way Jon and Daenerys
are gonna be able to have time to remove
her from power
now that the army of the Dead are south
of the wall and heading straight towards
Winterfell they have no choice but to
take care of the night king first and by
the looks of the night Kings army I am
not as hopeful as I once was the night
king must have been hiding a big
majority of his army because it looked
massive during the last scene without
the help of the entire realm I'm not so
sure John and Daenerys can win with what
they have right now if the night King
has his giant used bow and arrows to
take down the dragons while he is riding
Vasari on I don't know if any of Danny's
dragons are gonna survive this series
especially after seeing how easily they
are being taken down already
Daenerys seriously needs to get her
dragons fitted in some kind of armor as
soon as possible and Bray needs to warn
everyone at Winterfell immediately about
what he just saw the castle walls need
to be fitted with their own scorpions
and they need to make giant arrows with
dragonglass tips so they can try to take
down Vasari on I don't know what the
hell kind of flame that was but a blew
right through the wall like it was
nothing
this was a wall that was built using
magical spells by the children of the
forest and it was still no match for the
dragon after watching the dragon pit
scene I am wondering if Qyburn could be
of some help he seemed very interested
in the white and it was pretty obvious
he was wondering what kind of
experiments he could do if he had a
specimen of his own the only problem is
Qyburn is still using his skills for
evil intentions but I am confident bran
will leave King's Landing and head north
himself in one of my previous breakdown
videos I said bran would end up teaming
back up with Tyrion one day but now I am
sure that will happen
seeing bran and Tyrion have their
conversation outside the dragon pit bran
acted like he wasn't interested in
Tyrion doubling his pay
but once Bronn finds out Jaime is gone
he will have no reason to stay in the
south and you can't have a character
like bran just leave the story now we
have seen how good Bronte's with the
Scorpion he means to take his talents
north and use them to take down visera
on with the dragon glass or Valyrian
steel tipped arrow I did really enjoy
the meeting at the dragon pit though I
loved seeing all these characters come
together and cross paths for the first
time but also loved all the reunions we
had one when Tyrion and Bronn Tyrion and
Podrick The Hound and Brienne the Hound
in the mountain Theon and Euron and I
think they all served their purposes as
sort of a foreshadowing for some things
for the future like I said before bran
will leave King's Landing too and head
north and the Hound and Brienne will end
up fighting side-by-side and Fiona is
now heading towards pike to try and get
Yara back and cleganebowl is still on
the table ladies and gentlemen it's not
going to happen anytime soon
but when the Hound delivered those
bone-chilling lines to the mountain you
just know those two have to square off
at some point if you're gonna give us
any kind of fan service you might as
well give us cleganebowl the writers are
gonna have to find a way to keep
everybody involved in a story though
what could get tricky considering how
things are playing out right now
Cersei said she was gonna let the dead
kill off her enemies then she would take
care of whatever was left so I'm not
sure how we're gonna see Cersei again
unless it's near the end of season 8
unless she decides to head north and
attack Jon and Daenerys from the south
while the night king and his army are
marching towards Winterfell
it's not going to take the knight King
very long to make it to Winterfell
but what I'm wondering is if jon is
going to be able to intervene before the
Dead get there if you look at a map you
can see the night king was closer to
Winterfell than John and Daenerys were
considering they weren't even at white
Harbor yet but the timelines aren't in
any type of order so the next time we
see Jon and Daenerys they might have
already arrived at white Harbor heading
north as the night King heads south from
east watch what I am afraid of is
they're gonna end this war against the
night king too quick the directions
everyone is heading in it's looking like
they're gonna clash headfirst at
Winterfell and if you think of the name
Winterfell this might be where winter is
going to fall again it seems like we
will get the big war against the living
in the dead first then we're gonna get
the war against Cersei last unless
everyone flees Winterfell to head south
but I don't think it's gonna happen like
that I know some people have been asking
me about the vision that bran had when
he could see the shadow of a dragon
flying over top of King's Landing some
of you have been speculating that this
might be the night King flying on
vissarion over King's Landing but I
don't think that is the case when Jamie
left King's Landing it was starting to
snow already but when you watch the
vision brain had you can see that King's
Landing was still sunny and there was no
snow on the rooftops if this was the
night King on the dead dragon in his
vision you would see snow everywhere
especially considering he usually brings
the storm with him Cersei might actually
be making the smart move again if she
lets John and Danny fight the night King
on their own then she can keep all of
her troops alive plus she will gain the
20,000 men from the golden company if
Jon and Daenerys are able to defeat the
night king with what they have they will
definitely take a significant amount of
losses and they won't have enough men
left over after the great war to defeat
Cersei in order for Jon and Daenerys to
be able to win both of these wars that
are gonna need to stop Cersei from
getting reinforcements from the golden
company and there are a few different
ways that could potentially be done I
know this is a long shot but just hear
me out if Theon can somehow catch up to
his uncle you're on and take him down he
might get all of the Ironborn on his
side then Theon in your could take your
on this entire fleet back to the north
killing Euron would take away Circe's
biggest alliance right now and it would
take away the golden companies
transportation to Westeros and this
would give Jon and Daenerys enough time
to regroup after they take care of the
night king but this is assuming they're
even going to be able to stop the night
King which isn't a guarantee right now
but fiona is on his way to save Yara and
if he can somehow pull this off I think
with Fiona and Yara together they can
sway the rest of the Ironborn that is
with Joran and they can convince them to
join the fight against the dead plus
they would gain Euron's massive fleet I
think Theon finally got some of that
closure he was looking for from Jon he
will always have PTSD after suffering
years of mental and physical abuse from
Ramsay but I think the conversation he
had with Jon really helped him heal some
of his wounds Theon has
felt absolutely terrible about betraying
the Starks and now I know some of you
can debate whether or not Phelan had a
good reason to betray them but Theon
himself has felt bad about this ever
since he realized his father would never
accept him for who he was he knew Ned
treated him better than his own father
ever would
he didn't need John to tell him this
that's why Theon told Ramsay his real
father died in King's Landing he was
talking about Ned Stark songs already
forgave Theon for what he did when he
saved her but Phelan probably didn't
think John ever would and this tore him
up inside back in season two when Theon
took over Winterfell maester Luwin told
Theon to join the Nights Watch otherwise
he would be taken prisoner because he
was surrounded by the Bolton's you could
see that Theon considered what maester
Luwin said for a split second but he
knew John would kill him if he ever
showed up at Castle black but Jon let
him live when they met again on the
beach only because he saved Sansa but
when John told Theon he was always going
to be a stark even though his last name
was Greyjoy this gave Theon that closure
and he gave him the courage he needed to
go out there and kick that guy's ass and
I think when Theon bent down into that
water and washed a blood away I think
this was kind of like a baptism for
Theon he was reborn again on this Beach
and we won't see him back down from
Euron ever again that's why I am
confident feelin's Redemption arc is not
over and that's why I believe he will be
the one to take down his uncle you're on
if fiown could take out you're on and
take over his fleet this would at least
momentarily cut off Cersei from getting
the golden company I am sure Cersei
would try and find another way to get
them to Westeros but this could buy
everybody some time another way Cersei
could be cut off from the golden company
as if by some crazy chance Daario is
somehow with them he could set Cersei up
and join forces with Daenerys again we
all know Daario wanted nothing to do
with marine and he was only there
because Daenerys was there and when she
told him to stay behind he was not happy
about that the only problem is the
golden company is well known for never
breaking a contract so it would be kind
of hard to believe they would not honor
their commitment to Cersei Lannister but
then again there is a first time for
everything this could be the perfect
he'll turn that Cersei would never be
expecting she would be confident
the golden company would uphold their
contract but if they came to Westeros
and turned her back on her that would be
pretty damn cool you know who did work
for the golden company at one time Jorah
Mormont was once a sell sword for the
golden company before he started
advising for Danny's brother Viserys the
golden company was founded by one in a
clan Targaryen bastard sons aegor rivers
which of course is an ancestor of
Daenerys and John the show writers could
try and tie this in with the storyline
somehow with the way things are being
written and done now I wouldn't be
surprised if the golden company's
connection to the Targaryen isn't
mentioned especially now that John's
true name was revealed as Aegon
Targaryen I don't want to reveal too
many things in this video because I have
plans on making a separate one but let's
just say there gonna be some interesting
things going on with this whole golden
company subplot in season 8 but since I
already mentioned Aegon Targaryen let's
just jump into the whole John and Danny
sex scene I have been saying for the
last few videos that I think John is
going to get Daenerys pregnant I think
we all knew they would have sex but they
have also been making it very obvious
that Danny would get pregnant again and
John even hit us right over the head
with it when he told the Narus she
shouldn't have taken the advice of marry
master John and Daenerys were even
playing with the broken skull of a baby
dragon
John handed it to Daenerys and this
could be a symbolic representation of
John giving Daenerys a baby dragon hover
on when he plants his seed inside her
that's just my opinion though but this
relationship is going to cause some
serious problems in the future
you could see the look on Tyrians face
when he knew John and Danny were having
sex
Tyrion can feel his influence in
position as the hand slipping further
and further away Tyrion also knows how
having a sexual relationship can
complicate things and continue to put
Daenerys in danger he knows Daenerys
already lost a dragon trying to save
John what else could she lose trying to
help John in the future she may end up
losing her life and Tyrion is visibly
concerned about this but this also
complicates things politically when John
finds out him and Daenerys are related
John might want to cut the relationship
off and this could be where Daenerys
feels her third betrayal John will still
want her as an ally but he might want to
cut the physical part off
especially if he starts feeling the heat
from outside influences but John is in
love so he might not care I am just as
curious about this as everyone else I
want to know what John and Daenerys will
do when they find out they are related I
want to know what Daenerys will do when
she finds out John has the stronger
claim to the throne than she does John
will never want the throne for himself
but Daenerys may still feel some type
away when she knows she isn't the
rightful heir after thinking this whole
time that she was it's going to get very
interesting to see how their dynamic
plays out when they both still need each
other now more than ever considering the
night King is heading right for them but
speaking about pregnancies we never did
see Cersei have that miscarriage so the
show must have cut that out for whatever
reason or we will see that happen next
season at the beginning I think instead
of Cersei having a miscarriage to
fulfill the Maggy the Frog prophecy I
think it would be better as she gave
birth to a dwarf after all the years of
abuse she has put Tyrion through I think
it would be a nice slap in the face if
she gave birth to a dwarf she would
quickly regret saying all those things
about Tyrion when he was born knowing
damn well he wasn't born with claws and
a tail I also want to mention something
else was it just me or did anyone else
think Jaime was about to be killed by
the mountain when Cersei gave him the
head nod and he pulled his sword out I
got very nervous
I did not want Jamie to die he still
needs to fulfill my prediction for me I
think Jaime will sacrifice himself
saving one of the Starks and possibly
even brand his story began with pushing
bran out of the window so I think it
could end with him saving bran or one of
the other Starks in some way I was so
happy to see Jaime finally leave Cersei
she has been the absolute worst
influence on him but now that he has
broke free from her grasp I have very
high hopes for Jaime Lannister
I love seeing Jaime without that
Lannister armor on but he didn't just
take it off because he was done with
Cersei he has to take it off or else he
could be killed on his way north that's
also why he put the glove on over his
golden hand so he could hide who he was
it's not because that golden hand was
actually cold
I am confident he will make it to
Winterfell and help out with the war and
that's where he will unite with Brienne
and Tyrion again and I am very excited
to see where Jamie's story heads next
Winterfell has now
stabilized a little bit after the death
a little finger saundarya are both fully
committed to John ruling the north
neither one of them have to worry about
Littlefinger ever influencing anyone's
opinion about who should rule but John's
birth name has yet to be revealed to
everyone and that can certainly change
things but how did you all feel about
Littlefinger's death was you satisfied
watching Arya cut his throat wide open
or would you have rather seen Songza do
it it kind of reminded me of the way
grey worm cut the throat of the slavers
back in Mereen I did love seeing
Littlefinger as vulnerable as he was he
had no more moves
no more lies to weasel his way out of
when brain started feet in
Littlefinger's quotes back to him he
about crapped his pants again
I loved how all of the Starks came
together as a pack to take down
Littlefinger bran revealed all of the
things Littlefinger thought no one in
the North would know and psalms are
revealed all the things Littlefinger
thought she would take to her grave and
Arya finally put him out of his misery
this was a big moment for all the
players left in the game Littlefinger
was one of the best to ever do it but
taking him off the board allows for them
to focus on what is truly important and
that is what is heading right at them
the night King and the army of the dead
should be knocking at Winterfell is gate
by season eight episode two at the
latest but as fast as everyone has been
traveling in this series now they could
be there in the season 8 premiere they
are already marching past the wall and
heading south and as of right now brain
is the only one that knows Eastwatch was
completely leveled to the ground so I
don't think anyone there could send a
message south even if they survived the
wall falling down onto everything and
crushing it I have always felt the big
battle would take place at Winterfell
simply because of all the connections
just to the ward winter alone the stark
words are winter is coming
and that never just meant the winter
weather is coming that also meant a king
of winter was coming from the lands of
always winter I think the night king
will be slain at Winterfell because
that's where the king of winter had
fallen before that's where the most epic
battle of all time will happen again but
this is just my opinion let me know what
you think about everything down in the
comments what are some of your
predictions heading into season 8 I
would like to hear what you think I want
to thank everyone for watching this
video I have barely scratched the
surface with this one this was just a
Jenna
overall view of everything I will be
making many more videos all year long
until the new season begins so I hope to
see you all back for those I also need
to thank all of you kind people who help
support this channel on patreon I hope
you all have a great day
bye